- Hi, everyone.
Can you hear me pretty well in the back?
Since it's so quiet over here,
I'm sure it's so easy to hear.
Anyways, my name is Rafa Flores.
Rafael Flores, Chief Product
Officer at Treasure Data.
Gonna be more excited to
spend my afternoon with y'all.
It's gonna be a quick 20 minutes,
but we're gonna have a
little bit of fun, okay?
So with that, today,
we're gonna talk a little bit
about data chaos to AI magic.
And everyone here has
been talking about AI,
but they're missing a critical piece,
which is, nobody's been
talking about data, right?
And so, I am gonna do that,
and I'm gonna try to bring it all together
because at the end of the day,
AI is only as good as what you feed it.
That is what we say at our organization,
and that is what I believe in,
also, as a technologist, right?
You need to ensure that
you upgrade the human brain
along with agentic by design products.
And that's exactly what
we're gonna talk about, okay?
Today, there's a lot of tools out there.
They're just interfaces.
You go and you chat, you put a prompt.
That's just an interface.
To many folks who may
not know AI very well
or are just trying to learn,
that seems like a very agentic
product, right? But it's not.
It's just a chat prompt,
calling on a model.
It's not as powerful, right?
What I wanna talk about
and what I wanna focus on
is actually the agentic brain
that's underneath that, right?
And if you really think
about where AI is headed,
a lot of people talk about
is it just hype, is it not?
Are there credible use
cases? Are there not?
Well, some are, some don't. Right?
And hopefully, over the
next 18 and a half minutes,
I can help you understand
what's gonna work
and what's not gonna work.
So, you try to avoid some of the things
that we have learned as an organization
in supporting our customers
who have embraced AI, right?
And I wanted to start with the metric,
which is actually pretty cool.
It says, "Gartner published
a report saying that,
'By 2027, 40% of AI first
projects will fail,'" right?
There's a thousand
reasons why they may fail,
but it's just a reality.
And when you're thinking about investing
into an AI native
product, you wanna ensure
that you're making the
investment worth the while.
You don't wanna be part of the statistic,
"In 2027 that says that
'40% failed,'" right?
So, how do we make sure
that you don't fail?
It's all about identifying
some of the gaps, right?
And there's two critical gaps
that I do wanna emphasize.
Number one, there's a readiness gap.
And there's a readiness gap
not so much just in terms of products,
but also in terms of your organizations.
You need to ensure that you're structured
in the proper way in-house to
even bring AI-native products
or AI-first initiatives into those teams.
You need to ensure that you
have the right use cases, right?
Use cases are still the same thing.
A use case is a use case. It's
there for a reason, right?
You have to ensure
that you know why you are
bringing in those initiatives.
Second problem, unifying disparate data.
That's not going away, right?
You can use AI to solve some of that,
but if you have messy data,
your AI is still not gonna be that strong.
And I'll walk you through
an actual example, right?
But you also have to think
about the current markets.
And this is a reality
that we all deal with across the board.
It's something we deal at Treasure Data,
something I'm sure all of you deal with.
And the reality is that the
budgets are not changing.
Budgets are a little bit constrained,
whether you're IT or marketing.
It's just a matter of fact, right?
And the price to compete is
actually gone up to be able
to get brand exposure, to
be able to land customers.
whether you're a B2B, B2C.
It's just tighter of a race.
Everyone's trying to win this race,
and it's just getting tighter
because, again, the budgets
haven't changed very much,
and the price of compete
has gone up, right?
And so, it's a little bit chaotic.
And then if you think
about macroeconomics,
everything going on in the world,
it gets even messier, right?
Every day you wake up,
you gotta think about AI.
You gotta think about,
okay, what is going on next?
So, how can I help you
leave that world, right?
And get to a better place
where you can actually go
and find solutions to some of the problems
that I have just talked about.
And that's where customer
data platforms come in, right?
Treasure Data, historically,
we have been a customer data platform.
We have become a AI-native marketing cloud
with the marketing super
agent at the top, right?
And again, the reason why
we have gone that route,
and the reason why I
believe in that mission is
because your AI is as good
as the data you feed it.
And there's a very much value
in your first-party data.
CDPs allow you to do that.
If you utilize quality data,
you can implement agents
that actually allow
you to be a superhuman.
Now, I don't believe that AI
and agents are here to take your job away.
And I kind of chuckle at that
'cause I'm sure some people say that,
or some of you may believe it.
This is my own opinion,
but as an organization,
we also believe in that
because we believe that
making you a superhuman
is giving you the right tooling
or the right AI products
to make you successful,
regardless of what functional
department you sit in.
Because ultimately, what we
wanna do is we wanna help IT
and marketers become super humans
and drive customer experience, right?
That is the job that many of you do.
And it's not just about
what marketing wants
or what IT wants,
it's ultimately what drives
your business forward, right?
And this friction, or this
dilemma has been around
for a long, long time.
Marketing wants this, IT complains,
IT doesn't wanna re-pipeline,
marketing complains.
Well, how can we ensure
that both teams get
the right tooling to ensure
that they can succeed?
Because ultimately,
their success is joint.
It's not disparate as much
as their data can also not be disparate.
Some of the common pitfalls
that we see, right?
As we work with a lot of global
2000 brands, there's four.
Scale, right?
If you have limited memory,
limited context in your AI,
it's hard to scale it.
And it's not just scale
and sense of performance,
it's scale in the sense
also of your use cases.
What are you trying to serve?
Number two, there's a common dilemma.
Do we build, do we buy, right?
It depends how you structure in-house.
If you have highly technical teams,
and you're ahead on the AI ball game,
then you should probably
continue down that path
and find ways to accelerate
or augment that with vendors.
If you don't have those teams,
then you should probably
be buy first, right?
'Cause it's gonna be a heavy investment
and a big uplift to try to do it yourself.
Data quality. We talked about this.
I cannot emphasize that enough,
right? Data quality matters.
AI is not just going
to solve every single
one of your problems.
If you go into ChatGPT today,
and you give it a bad prompt,
that is bad data quality,
that is also gonna be a bad response.
And that is not a bad model.
It's just your prompt was bad, right?
And so, if you're also giving that
to your autonomous
engines in the background,
bad data, bad output.
And then AI adoption. It's
a real challenge, right?
Every company that I meet
with, every CMO that I talk to,
it's not just about embracing AI,
it's also, okay, how do
we make the best of it?
How do we ensure that we
consume those credits?
How do we make sure
that we actually engage
and our teams are gonna
go and chat, right?
With those interfaces?
That's a real pitfall.
And that, again, ties to
the fact that you need
to ensure that you have
use cases at the top.
You can't talk about
adoption if you don't talk
about the use case for
the business, right?
And so, there's five
tips that I'll give you
to ensure that your AI
actually succeeds and works.
Now, you can see them all here.
I see some of you taking photos.
I'll wait a quick second,
but I'll go through them
one at a time, okay?
And we'll dive into the weeds of it.
Number one, you have to ensure
that when you look at an AI vendor
and you have at the top
of your mind the concept
of AI and data equals the
proper personalized experiences.
You gotta ensure that they can
do identity-resolved memory.
What does that mean?
That means giving you a source
of truth profile, right?
The golden record era is, to me, that.
Today, you're more entering
an era of the diamond record.
Something that you're more in control of.
Something that's not just deterministic
or probabilistic in nature,
but it's agentic in nature, right?
That you have full control,
that you can fully trust,
so that when you target that person,
it's actually the person
you need to target.
And it's not just wasting
precious marketing and IT dollars.
Number two, context at inference,
every interaction matters
most, more than ever, right?
The concept of real-time
matters now more than ever. Why?
If you have the latest behaviors,
forget about attributes,
forget about just the profile.
If you have the latest behaviors
to the milliseconds, right?
You actually ensure that
anything you put on autopilot
is being delivered at the right time
to the right person
across the right channel.
If you don't have that, you
could be missing a moment.
And many of you have seen that, right?
How many of you here in the
audience have made a purchase
and then you get an email the next day
or the same day saying, hey, you should go
and purchase X, but you just bought it.
You already bought it.
And you're not the only
one that got that email.
Imagine how many of those emails went out.
That also means you spent some bucks
sending those emails out,
or somebody did, right?
It cost the company something.
It wasn't free, because it's
not context at inference.
It's not in real-time.
You need to ensure your AI vendors work
and operate in real-time.
Number three, governance and trust.
Extremely important.
You don't wanna be that automotive company
that put a chat bot on their website
and suddenly, somebody was
able to go and get a free car.
You'll make the news,
free brand dollars, right?
But not for good reason.
And so, you have to ensure
that you're built on the concept of trust.
It's not so much just the
data, right? It's also the AI.
If you can trust the data,
and you can trust the AI, you
can actually use that vendor.
I always tell our customers, right?
They always come to us and say,
"Hey, why should we use your
AI product versus X versus Y?
Why should we trust it?"
And my answer to them is the
same answer I'll give y'all,
which is, you already trust us
with your most critical resource.
And that is all the IP
of PI information we have
of your consumers or your shoppers,
or who you're trying to target, right?
If something was to happen to that data,
they will actually have major lawsuits,
but they trust us because we
have a proven record with it.
So, if you trust us with your data,
you can trust us with
our AI as well, right?
And, but you have to have
this at the forefront.
And one of the reasons we're here at AWS
is we work very closely with them, right?
We use bedrock within our architecture
because of all the bells
and whistles it comes with
from a trust and governance
standpoint to ensure
that our brands that we
serve can actually operate.
And they're not worried that
they're gonna get a lawsuit
because their AI or their data broke.
Number four, feedback loops.
It's not just getting data in real-time,
it's also iterating on that data, right?
If you go and build a journey,
how many of you here are
familiar with journeys?
There's a few. Okay.
If you go and you build a journey,
a journey is a path of, hey,
this profile here off of floors
of Treasure Data who likes
to buy X car, goes down a
journey of how do we get him
to actually purchase the next vehicle
across different channels
based on different signals.
Well, any pivot in me as a potential buyer
should be accounted for in that journey,
which means you need to
account for feedback loops.
'Cause any change that I do in my actions
or interactions needs to be accounted for
in those feedback loops.
And it has to, again, be in real-time.
If you miss the moment,
you miss the moment,
you won't get it back, okay?
So you gotta capture the signals.
You gotta make sure you iterate on it.
Number five, it has to be
an extensible ecosystem.
What do I mean by that, right?
It sounds like two big words
and something that I
just pull out of a hat.
In the world of data platforms,
there's a concept of where
should the data reside?
Should it sit in my data warehouse?
Should it sit in my activation channel?
Should it sit in my CDP?
What do I do with it?
It doesn't matter, right?
Wherever your data sits,
you need to have a vendor
that can pull that data without
charging you extra for it,
so you could use it, right?
And the concept of compostability
has really risen in the past few months
because companies are trying
to adopt and embrace AI.
And so, when they're trying
to get an agent out the door,
they wanna feed it all the data they have.
And that data could be in
a lot of systems, right?
The MarTech stack or Adtech
stack, it's pretty broad.
And so, you should be
able to pull that, right?
And so, that means that
you gotta make sure
that you have an open ecosystem.
And here's a great example.
I love this visual because when
we talk about compostability
and where should the
data reside for your AI,
everyone talks about zero copy, right?
We need to have zero copy.
We need to ensure that we can just move
the data free flow and et cetera.
The concept of zero copy,
and I can tell you this from
a very technical background
of mine, doesn't really exist.
If any vendor tells you
that they are zero copy,
that's actually not true.
There's always a some sort of copy
for a specific set of use cases.
If you want to do things in real-time,
you have to have a copy of that data
in your activation
channel because you have
to have a trigger that actually goes
and engages that person
or engages that brand.
That's a copy. It's not zero copy.
That's a copy, right?
And so, when you really
think about it, historically,
if you go back many years
ago, you have four copies.
Your systems. I wish
I had a pointer, okay?
Your systems, data warehouse,
CDP, email service provider.
And then we moved away from that, right?
And we said, well, compostable CDPs.
Now, you have the channel
where the data's coming from
to your data warehouse,
to your activation layer.
Well, in this new world,
if you really wanna be
in a zero-copy-type of environment,
your data's always gonna come in
from a specific touchpoint
into your data warehouse.
And it should be able
to flow anywhere, right?
It shouldn't have to sit in your CDP.
It shouldn't have to sit in
your email service provider.
You should be able to really
pull it from anywhere you want.
But again, it's, there's two copies.
So, if there's anything
you take away from this,
other than the fact that
we're cool and bad ass
at Treasure Data, take
it that there's no such
a thing as zero copy in the world.
Where does that bring us, right?
I want you to actually meet something
that's really cool in
this new era of agent
and intelligence, right?
And we talked about earlier,
the interface versus the brain.
Every prompt, every chat
you go on, again, interface.
But you need more than that.
And if you bring in the right data,
you make it agentic by design.
Now, this is our latest product.
It's called a marketing super agent.
Now, what it does is it's connected
to your first-party data.
So, it's not just going
and calling on models
and pulling in deep research information
or doing deep analysis
from anywhere in the web,
which is powerful, don't get me wrong.
But you have valuable resources.
You have first-party data in-house today.
This allows you to pull from
that plus everything else.
So, if you want to go on here
and just create a nurture
journey campaign, you can, right?
And it's doing everything.
Campaign programs is looking at content.
It's creating digital assets.
It's looking at competitive landscape,
and it's doing the data
analysis within your CDP
or within your data warehouse,
wherever your data resides.
Now, this is a 32nd clip of it.
If you wanna learn more,
you can go to Booth 235.
We'll show you a full demo of it.
But that is what we talked
about when we state,
hey, we need to ensure
that you use agentic
by design products, right?
The agentic brain because the brain is
as good as you train it.
Your model is as good as you train it
with the right data set.
It's very simple.
Every company is gonna
have agents. We have 'em.
Many vendors here have
them. It's nothing new.
The ones that are gonna win are those
that actually have brains that are powered
by data that's contextual.
It goes back to, again,
being able to give context on inference.
It's gonna be governed.
It goes back to trust and governance,
and it's gonna be in real-time
because you need to account
for every single interaction
to make it meaningful and be impactful.
Now, I'd earlier that AI is not
gonna replace your team or you, right?
And I do believe that.
I've heard the whole era of
BDRs are gonna go and disappear.
This has been a dilemma
for the last 20 years.
And poor BDRs are still around,
and they serve a good purpose, right?
And right now, there's
a lot of that going on
and there's a lot of
fear that AI is racing.
Don't be scared of AI. My
biggest advice is to use,
embrace it.
Embrace it to your advantage.
Make the best of it.
Use it as a tool. I use
it, as CPO of this company.
I love this quote.
And the reason why I love this quote is
from a head of product over at Google,
he set the 80-20 rule,
which I agree with, right?
"If you can put 80% of
things on autopilot,
the mundane things, the things
that you don't wanna do,
the things that you go
and clock into your job
and you just say, 'Oh, man, I gotta do
that report again,'" right?
But then there's that 20%
that's always gonna
require the human element.
Focus a hundred percent
of your time on that 20%.
And that'll make it so much more impactful
because in the current era of AI,
you need to be able to focus.
You can't put everything on autopilot.
Some things are gonna be copilot.
Some things you're
always gonna have to do,
brand guidance reviews,
the feelings you want to
evoke as a brand or company,
they come from you to a human, right?
So there's humans in the loop,
and I want you to take that
away from this session as well.
So with that, I got two minutes
left. Thank you so much.
I can take a question or
two before they boot me off,
but any questions?